Chitral est la plus grande ville de la vallée.
Toutes les marchandises de 1re nécessité y sont stockées
avant de partir ravitailler les villageois installés à flanc de montagne le long de la frontière avec l'Afghanistan.
Le village de Parsan se situe à 35 km à peine de Chitral.
Accroché à 2 900 m d'altitude, ce petit village est totalement enclavé.
Chasse, agriculture, élevage, les 1 500 habitants y vivent en autarcie, complètement isolés du reste du Pakistan.
Pour rejoindre Parsan, il n'existe qu'une seule solution :
s'aventurer sur cette route de pierres creusée depuis à peine une dizaine d'années.
Retour à Chitral.
Dès les 1res heures de la journée, les passagers se pressent par dizaines à la gare centrale.
Chacun tente de trouver une place dans l'un des véhicules à destination de son village.
- Ici, c'est la gare des 4x4.
Ce sont les seuls véhicules capables de franchir la montagne car les camions ne passent pas.
Hadji a 28 ans. Il conduit la Jeep qui mène au village de Parsan.
Comme son père avant lui, il assure plusieurs fois par semaine la lourde charge de transporter les villageois.
Aujourd'hui, il doit remonter une famille sur cette route réputée des plus dangereuses,
mais son véhicule a un problème mécanique.
- Ca va aller ?
- Oh là là ! Ca fuit de partout, là !
- Ils ont besoin de moi au village. Je suis le seul moyen de transport.
Par exemple, si quelqu'un tombe malade, c'est à moi de m'en occuper et de le transporter.
Alors je dois faire réparer la Jeep le plus rapidement et repartir au plus vite.
Malheureusement, le problème est plus important que prévu. Une pièce de la transmission est totalement usée.
- Regarde, elle est foutue, ta pièce !
- Tu as l'air inquiet.
- Oui. C'est très difficile de trouver une pièce comme celle-ci.
Comment vas-tu faire ?
- Je ne sais pas. Là, j'ai un gros problème.
Trouver une pièce de précision dans un village perdu au milieu de la montagne relève du parcours du combattant.
- Bonjour. Je cherche cette pièce.
- On n'a pas ça ici.
- Bonjour. Tu as ça, toi ?
- Non, j'ai pas ce genre de pièce. Laisse-moi dormir.
- Non, non, j'ai pas ce modèle.
- Arrête de chercher, tu trouveras jamais.
Le salut viendra peut-être de cette dernière boutique.
- 2, 4, 6, 8...
C'est bon pour toi. C'est la bonne pièce.
Ca fait 40.
2 heures plus tard, la Jeep est réparée, prête pour affronter de nouveau la montagne.
Hadji charge près d'une tonne de marchandises, mais aussi des passagers.
Solana, 10 mois, et ses parents ont le sourire.
Après 15 jours d'hospitalisation pour une grosse fièvre, leur petite fille peut enfin rentrer au village.
- Malgré les dangers, on va remonter par cette route. Il n'existe pas d'autre accès au village.
- Tu te fais du souci pour ta famille ?
- Oui. J'ai surtout peur pour ma petite.
- Bonne route !
- Merci, merci !
Par manque de place, une dizaine de personnes sont entassées à l'arrière de la Jeep.
Privilège pour la famille, Hadji les a installés à ses côtés.
- On va mettre un peu de musique.
Avant de s'engager dans la montagne, il faut franchir la rivière et rouler sur un antique pont de bois.
- Ce pont est très vieux. Il a été réparé plusieurs fois, mais il reste fragile. On n'aime pas le traverser.
Ecoute le bruit qu'il fait.
Personne ne prend le risque de s'arrêter dessus.
Après le pont, tout l'enjeu du voyage est d'atteindre le village avant la nuit.
Dormir dans les montagnes pourrait s'avérer fatal pour le groupe.
Les températures chutent souvent en dessous de zéro et les avalanches de pierres sont fréquentes.
De nombreuses Jeep se sont déjà fait emporter.
A cette altitude, la chaleur est épouvantable. En journée, il fait au minimum 40 degrés au soleil.
Le copilote tente régulièrement de refroidir le moteur.
Après 3 heures de route, les passagers sont exténués. Ils n'avaient pas prévu cette chaleur.
- Solana, ma chérie...
T'inquiète pas, on va bientôt arriver. On va bientôt arriver.
Elle a soif, la petite.
- On n'a plus d'eau.
- Maintenant, c'est l'endroit le plus dangereux. On doit passer le tunnel de la mort.
Qu'Allah nous protège.
Dieu est grand, il va nous aider à passer.
Il le faut !
Le tunnel de la mort est un passage d'une dizaine de kilomètres creusé à la main.
Sa voûte est instable. Les éboulements y sont si fréquents que des ouvriers le déblaient chaque jour.
- Quand la route a été construite, 2 ouvriers sont morts. Ils ont glissé dans le ravin.
Et maintenant, tout le monde a peur de venir ici.
Une traversée sans encombre, mais une victoire de courte durée.
A la sortie du tunnel de la mort, la rivière est en crue. Impossible de passer avec la Jeep.
Il va falloir passer la nuit sur place.
- Descends à la rivière ! Va regarder.
On a un gros problème, le courant est trop fort, c'est impossible de traverser maintenant.
Je ne pense pas qu'on passera aujourd'hui.
Inquiète, la maman de Solana ne sait plus quoi penser.
Quelques passagers intrépides tentent tout de même de franchir la rivière à leurs risques et périls.
- C'est impossible. Je réussirai jamais.
C'est infranchissable.
- Vraiment ?
- Ah ouais, c'est infranchissable.
Un jeune téméraire insiste à son tour.
Une rivière infranchissable, une nuit froide qui se rapproche, les parents de Solana ne peuvent plus attendre.
- On part à pied. On ne peut pas prendre le risque de rester bloqués ici cette nuit.
On a beaucoup de marches pour arriver jusqu'à notre maison. Mais on n'a plus le choix.
Maintenant, faut y aller.
Sous un soleil de plomb, la famille commence son ascension.
- Porte notre fille, s'il te plaît. J'en peux plus.
Cette voie secondaire uniquement praticable à pied date de l'époque où la route n'existait pas.
Inquiété par la montée des eaux, le grand-père est descendu à la rencontre de sa famille.
- Regarde, ma chérie, on voit la maison, là-haut.
Il faut au minimum 3 heures de marche pour atteindre la maison familiale.
- Ca va, ça va. Prends la petite.
- Viens avec moi, ma chérie.
- Couche-la, elle est fatiguée.
Quand ma famille prend la route, j'ai peur. Je ne sais jamais s'ils vont arriver en vie.
Alors je descends toujours à leur rencontre pour les attendre au bord de la route
et les aider s'ils ont un problème, comme aujourd'hui.
Et maintenant, tout va bien. Je suis rassuré.
- Couvre-la, s'il te plaît. Il faut qu'elle dorme. Elle est très fatiguée.
A l'extérieur, le père de famille a déjà repris le tissage de la laine.
Il utilise une méthode ancestrale qui n'a pas changé depuis des siècles.
- On tisse la laine à la maison, puis on descend la vendre en ville.
C'est comme ça que l'on gagne un peu d'argent.
Y a pas d'autre solution dans le village.
La laine sera vendue 2 euros le mètre sur le marché de Chitral,
tout juste de quoi acheter quelques vêtements pour la famille et payer les voyages en Jeep.
Devant le gué, l'espoir est revenu.
Le niveau de l'eau redescend peu à peu, et pour faciliter le passage des Jeep,
les villageois tapissent le lit de la rivière avec des cailloux.
- Le courant est toujours très fort. On peut pas encore passer.
Alors on jette des pierres.
- Allez, allez ! Tous ensemble !
Allez, les gars ! Allez, on y va ! Allez ! Tous ensemble ! Poussez !
Encore ! Poussez !
- C'est bien, on va pouvoir passer. Je suis content !
J'ai fait descendre les passagers. C'est trop dangereux.
Allez, remontez ! On y va !
Après quelques kilomètres, le village de Parsan apparaît enfin.
- Passe-moi le sac de sucre, s'il te plaît.
Hadji a mis 10 heures pour parcourir 35 km, mais il a le sourire.
Car une fois de plus, il a réussi à tromper la mort.
- Je suis heureux. J'ai rejoint mon village, mes amis, ma famille.
Dieu a été avec nous, encore une fois.